i'm trying to create the biggest moments
in hip-hop what was that like though
like crazy because i've been to summer
jam three times and
it's like people don't who've never been
it's like uh the energy's crazy it's
like i'm i've never been to summer jam
before this time i said well just as an
artist thing i was writing producers so
in my head i was just like i don't even
want to go to summer gym unless like i'm
maybe you hear your [ __ ] that you
produced or or you're performing you
know i'm saying or something like that
yeah so like with
somebody especially as a new yorker
summer gym that's like that's like the
grammys that's like you know the holy
grail man
and it was like rainy as [ __ ] right it
was stupid rainy that's why they didn't
perform the third time and that's why i
was fired because when
it rained
the festival stage got canceled the one
outside right yeah and everybody was
like oh man so it's all about if it was
any chance because i was there there was
no advertising that i was going to
perform everybody thought i was going to
perform at all so when
the rain started and they canceled the
festival stage everybody thought it was
clipped for that
i was performing on the main stage